i have never used an online dating
service
that's the first that's the first video
today's topic sgt divorced his wife
after discovering wife was an escort
so a new york city spine surgeon dr ham
jo kim divorces former miss connecticut
regina turner claims she's been escorted
kim says he first discovered this when
scrolling through imessage and found the
text between regina and a man regarding
sexual favors in december of 2020. the
doctor claimed to have learned of his
wife's double life after he separated
becoming aware that she
has been exchanging sexual services for
receipts of money with multiple men
before as well as during the marriage
according to court filings
she claims to have covered her secret
sex work by telling her husband that
she's spending time developing an app
and receiving venture capital funding
i mean they were definitely funding
something but it wasn't your bank
account you feel me that was a bank
account she got a sperm bank i had it
was a bank
banks a bank and they donated let me let
me fill both banks yes isn't that crazy
man's a spine surgeon
so while he's over there fixing spine
she was getting her back broken
yo man if this was brokeback mountain
he'd be the asian guy not getting any
no no you're saying like court documents
also say that
she lied about her education she
supposedly been completing a chemistry
major at the university of connecticut
until she took a break to complete to
compete in the miss usa pageant
though the documents claim she never
even completed high school
hey what up sister and you know what i
can't even matter i'm a high school
dropout i'd be a big old hypocrite
if i said anything about her so
shout out to another high school dropout
finances bank subpoena show that she may
have earned as close to 700 000 from
2015 to 2021.
i have never used an online dating
service
that's the first that's the first video
i bet you are the online dating service
you are tinder bumble you are
self-served
i've never used an online dating service
but back page is my [ __ ]
that's the clip that you're going to
pull up hold up
i don't even know how it's going to
start
that's that's just questions that they
have to answer these pageants okay yeah
make it sound like they know some [ __ ] i
appreciate that she's very concerned
with what's being taught in school
considering the fact that she's a high
school dropout
i would not feel comfortable in a
tastefully nude photo shoot yeah
y'all are trolling
here we go let's go
let's go y'all trolls it's all about
image bro it's going to get better let's
go
put press play it's nice this is nice
y'all trolling this is this is nice this
is gold right there this is gems just
young
you know listen photo shoots
gross
but hoenn
but you know that's the error of
respectability
okay that's my dick
[Laughter]
this is cringe
what the hell
why
what the [ __ ] am i watching
i guarantee you the guys who work at
like these pageant shows are like
what what what dumb [ __ ] can we make
these models say motorboat because like
you know it's some ugly gremlin behind
the camera being like i have control now
you know how much imagination i have
from dungeons and dragons
yo hi could you please make noises like
a cat for me
she went meow
okay okay okay now do the votes now now
let me ask you a question
do your best impersonation of a dungeon
master
what's a dungeon master oh
she said
[Laughter]
yo that has to be your nastiest [ __ ]
character you ever have yeah goddamn
yeah every now and then when i'm
masturbating i use it
all right
it still says cat yeah but maybe he
thought that's the car that's a cat
purring
or maybe she's just like oh cat which
cat did you mean because my other one
does a little
i'll do both for you meow and
hey man if you guys have ever heard that
noise in bed by accident it's always
followed by a quietness and a sorry
[Laughter]
every time that i've been clapping here
you're clapping a girl from behind and
sometimes you pull out and then you pull
back in and it makes them
yeah there's a girl and there's a quiet
period the girl goes sorry
guys leave a comment or like below if
you guys have ever
started
of course
our ladies if you said
you guys have to say don't worry about
it i'll do it again
[Music]
that's how you know you grew up in
suburbia
so you know you grow
if that's your idea of what a police
siren's like that means you haven't
heard that [ __ ] yeah you don't know the
real thing
[Applause]
do the real [ __ ]
why
[Laughter]
and there's traffic
[Applause]
yo rate that impression out of ten that
[ __ ] was crazy that's a 12 [ __ ]
all right let's go
hi i'm regina miss connecticut and i'm
maxine's new ad exec you would think for
a big ass like company like maxim they
would get like some decent sound
equipment what the [ __ ] is that hissing
noise
sound or even look i see you
i could definitely see how she got all
that money
yeah i could definitely see it
you can
i could i can't i could definitely see
it i could see it yeah i might try it
but i could see it
you know it's good
i mean it's not my type either but i
like filling me on sometimes
yeah saute some mushrooms put on a plate
i'm having that
well i do work as an oral surgeon's
assistant when i'm not modeling
[Laughter]
that's a decade-long troll this is you
can
[Laughter]
that's funny oral surgeon oral assistant
gag
you need some my assistance with that
sir got got goggle
rubble rubble rubble yo son this is the
biggest pause i've ever seen
i do some office work when i'm not
assisting surgery
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] what did she say
you know what
maybe it's because i already know she's
home so everything sounds like she's
still home yeah you know what i mean
oh she was beholding back then
that sounds like it dr kim is trying to
avoid the marriage on the basis of fraud
stay in school
aka dr kim's hoping not to lose all his
money to a [ __ ] who was basically
fleecing him for his money and lying
about how much money she made
good damn good for her damn
what do you mean what's being good for
her look for her do you think
really
felices are gay
well i mean she's married to the man
when she's lying about the fact that
she's escorted fleece is her game but
good for her i mean there's nothing
that's good for her doesn't mean like oh
good for you i'm like good for you i
mean whatever she got caught it's not so
much i'm like i don't wish her well
whatever this is this is a
this is a gold digger extraordinaire
this is she got the bag from the dude
and she get another bag from the dude
and she's going to leave him so she can
go do whatever the [ __ ] she wants
to get the back she's not a gold digger
she a platinum digger you feel me like
there's some people that like that they
like the last style they like
they like their lifestyles
yeah it's gratification gratification
people may paying for the box for them
that's their [ __ ]
it's
like that yeah some women are really
like there's there's like oh i'm worth
this it puts an amount on what they're
worth you know what i mean
it's it goes deep it really goes deep
but yeah
some people are like that you could be g
could be with a spine surgeon or
whatever with someone making a prince
from dubai she would still be hoeing
because that's that's her thing and you
know the money that he gives one thing
but being
being being wanted by other men is
another thing he's a spine surgeon when
you lead with your money don't surprise
when she goes after a bigger fish
because at the end of the day you might
be a spine surgeon
but you ain't not a ceo of bank of
america you feel me there's always
somebody with more money than you so if
that's what you're leading with when you
attract her don't be surprised when she
go for more i don't think that's the
issue but carry on what do you mean
that's because i think the issue is what
i said but keep on what do you mean that
some women just like sex work yeah i
think she likes it i think she likes it
the monday he gives her doesn't gratify
her you understand what i'm saying but
whenever she go get other bags like that
it gratifies oh people want her you know
i mean there's other people than one
person you know she's not for that just
one person what gratifies her was give
her gratification is other people paying
for a box so i don't think it's like
because other people are leading with
money or something like that it's just
the gratification that all this money is
giving to her it quantifies her value it
doesn't matter because if he leads with
money and that's what he use if he leads
with money to attract women then that's
all they're going to be there for it
doesn't you're right you know i'm saying
at the end of the day it's like she
might be about whatever she is yeah if
that's what you're offering her you're
just giving her what she wants yeah
right and so at the end of the day if
that's what she came in there for she
has no loyal to you only to the cash
true right
financially
so it's like you can buy the loyal
loyalty which is not really real so
that's so that's the thing it's it's a
it's a tough thing right because you see
this often you see us often with people
who make a lot of money right because
then they think like all right now i'm
making money the marriage and everything
is gonna come along and everybody's
gonna that's not the way it works you
can't buy people's affection inherently
you can buy some let me refresh you can
buy the affection
buying their loyalty buying their
that's a different story that's a
different story
and especially with the confines of
marriage where once they can divorce you
they can get the money out of you
yeah you can have a hard time making
that [ __ ] work so
anyways that's a separate video and
itself but yeah don't leave with money
when dr kim asked turner how she
supported herself she said that she
lived off a 500 000 inheritance from her
great grandmother
i'm not mad at you hohen you prob you
put me ma in this no i'm not mad at you
hoenn but like you you brought your
great grandmother you popped me up in
heaven just chilling all of a sudden she
feel like a burn mark come up like the
devil just left like oh what the [ __ ]
kind of sin did i get involved with well
why why did you get mima in this you
know i mean she survived world war two
me my dead right she died afterwards my
mother did nothing to you you know i
mean
she never even seen a smartphone god
damn you got to put mima in this like
[ __ ] i need to lie from work
like my grandma did and then their
grandma died she's really using her
ancestors to get out of like
damn the consequences of hoe and that's
crazy happen why'd you cheat
uh you know my grandfather taught me
that like a real man's worth is by how
many women he can
i'm not gonna pitch with my grandfather
if i get caught [ __ ] up she brought
her great grandmother i can't believe
you did that can i ask
ancestors why do you think she skipped
grandma because grandma's probably in
that hold on too she's probably alive in
hoenn
i don't know why are you disrespecting
our ancestors because she does it for
free
just because she do don't you yes true
all right respect on regina turner's
grandmother probably because she was
alive that's what i was going to say
that's what i said no just she's alive
and holy
i'm i'm happy that
what grandmas are holding
what
you need to go out there and see
grandma's hoeing they'd be hoeing baby
owen once started a sex podcast he's
just like man listen the fetishes are
everywhere no no it's not that it's me
being out there
it's me being out there being a bouncer
i've seen too many shits
i've seen too many things bro
i've seen too many things hey man listen
i don't know if this guy's gonna get his
marriage uh
annulled for fraud i think he got
fleeced and he's gonna have to hold this
big old l
hey man listen marriage is not a joke
especially for guys with money
take precautions all right
get your prenups done
but i have a prenups don't work they do
if you know what the [ __ ] you're doing
okay
get her a lawyer get yourself a lawyer
get it done properly protect yourselves
let me get this template let me get a
template of a prenup online no i'm just
telling y'all a lot of you ladies gonna
be
yeah and listen
like i tell you man the hotter they are
the odds of this happening are much more
elevated so
yeah i mean you went from miss
connecticut bruh you know what's funny
about these magazines i guarantee you
but like maxine i guarantee you
there's a contact at maxim who's in
contact with these high rich people he
contacts the president maxim's like i
want to get her contact info easy peasy
like that
a lot of these like high-end spots even
whether it be playboy max and all these
things like that
get these women in contact with rich
dudes
for some home
that's called a booking agent
yeah not legally though
it's booking for company so it depends
how you put it in the eyes of the law so
more like a liaison
booking agency you know what i'm saying
the guys who are really rich what they
do is they donate the money to maxim or
whatever it is whatever company okay
they try to just knock it and then
they'd be like give me give me the
contacts because i want miss this girl
from this month for
work
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and you guys might be wondering abba how
would you know because i happen to know
somebody who works in one of these
little magazines and they'd be telling
me some stuff that they see behind the
scenes some of their rich donors and how
it works out
that's right
does it mean that all these women are
home no sir
but does that mean that some of them are
yes sir your favorite instagram model
might
they some of them
a lot of them i've already talked about
that but anyways we're not gonna get
that today but like i said guys you know
you got money that's great don't leave
with money all right because if that's
all she
she came for and that's all you give her
well that's all she's going to keep and
then she go for something else so is
there anything else you want to add
anything insightful nah good for her
the way you say that it makes it sound
like you are condoning what you're doing
no i'm not
at the end of the day she cheated on the
man not only that she was taking money
for sex she lied about her income
basically the whole marriage was a fraud
from the jump so you know i feel for the
guy he's going to lose a lot of money
it's actually pretty sad uh but at the
same time guys you guys go for vain
beautiful women don't be surprised when
they have no character
[Music]
foreign